m
c'est tout 2006 le complexe
pénitentiaire de sainte-anne-des-plaines
va bientôt perdre un de ses plus
célèbres détenus
c'est un personnage presque mythique
habitait ici depuis presque deux ans
vito rizzuto pendant 25 ans il a été le
chef incontesté de la mafia au canada
son empire du crime c'est à l'aise sur
quatre continents
mais aujourd'hui sa chance ne le suis
plus les tours et du tout vient de
perdre son dernier appel pour éviter son
extradition aux états unis
la justice américaine va le condamner à
dix ans de prison pour son rôle dans un
triple meurtre survenu à new york en
normalement calme aujourd'hui il
semblait ébranlé et nerveux il prétend
être le seul à pouvoir maintenir la paix
entre les différentes organisations
criminelles à montréal aux policiers
qu'ils escortent les met en garde contre
les gangs de rue la force et émergents
du crime organisé à montréal
un jet du fbi à et attend régit tout à
l'aéroport montréal trudeau en voyant
l'avion est juste on réalise que cette
fois ci il n'échappera pas à la justice
ces photos sont les dernières de pitau
résultats au canada mais depuis on en a
beaucoup appris sur l'étendue de son
empire
une pieuvre alimentée par le crime mais
qui étend ses tentacules dans de
nombreuses entreprises légitimes
[Musique]
g
juin 2010 et sa rame
six ans après son arrestation l'ombre de
vito rizzuto plane dans sept salles de
cours où un enquêteur chevronné de la
grc de montréal témoigne l'organisation
des rezzous taux était une organisation
très structurée
le sergent le remake de google suit à la
trace la mafia canadienne depuis des
années on le voit ici dans le procès de
beignes animaux appiah accusé par la
justice italienne d'avoir tenté de
blanchir 600 millions de dollars à
travers plusieurs pays pour le compte du
clan des régies tôt en 2003 quand on a
commencé notre enquête on a observé une
personne qui arrivait de l'italie cette
personne est bnj animaux zappia le
sergent macdougall a suivi à au moins
six reprises à montréal notamment
quartier général du clan résultat le
club social comme senza où la police
avait caché des micros et des caméras
[Musique]
oui c'est le monsieur aussi en arrière à
la droite il m'a vu un corridor ce matin
quelqu'un m'a identifiés pour lui alors
il m'a vu de nombreuses fois mais il ne
l'a pas réalisé d souvent suivies au
canada à rome le sergent mac do good
racontera pendant des heures comment
l'organisation rezulteo est devenu
puissante
tout le monde avait peur des rizzuto tu
ne défilait pas l'organisation risotto
ils étaient trop puissants
la plupart des grosses importation de
cocaïne et de haschisch des années 80 90
étaient destinés à la mafia montréalaise
andré cédilot a suivi le crime organisé
à montréal pendant 20 ans pour le
quotidien la presse
il vient tout juste de publier un livre
sur la mafia montréalaise
les russes devront importer le système
mafieux italiens ici presque à l'état
pur c'est les liens du sang qui les unit
pour éviter la délation aux autres la
fameuse loi d'omerta des liens familiaux
c'est très important
la mafia n'hésitent pas à recourir à la
violence et même à tuer pour s'imposer
dans le milieu à montréal ses membres
disposent d'un arsenal impressionnant
comme le démontrent ses images captées
par des caméras cachées de la police
dans un garage de la rue saint-laurent
dans le cadre de l'opération antimafia
colisée leurs menaces glace le sang
comme c'est si capté au téléphone des
menaces adressées parfois à des hommes
d'affaires
[Musique]
aux menaces s'ajoutent les enlèvements
comme celui survenu au soir de
l'halloween 2005 d'un proche du clan
rizzuto
nicolas barret kelly aux mains d'un
groupe rival il a été enlevé alors qu'il
donnait des bonbons aux enfants sur
cette cassette saisis par la police ont
l'instinct supplié ses patrons de la
mafia pendant plus d'une heure de
négocier avec son ravisseur
pour éviter un carnage dans ce même
enregistrement var accueille on se dit
prêt à mourir pour la cause de ce qu'il
appelle des hommes d'honneur
[Musique]
vito rizzuto a réussi pendant son règne
à se rallier tout le milieu criminel y
compris les attentes jose et le clan
matticks l'aéroport montréal trudeau
avait même été infiltrés par la mafia
la preuve a révélé que l'organisation
avait corrompu une douanière qui
travaillait à l'aéroport de montréal la
douane et avait été trouvé coupable de
corruption
madame cd nous dégager des points
conclut même occasion suggère
contredanses au 28 janvier doit
fonctionner du tout on vient alors je
trouve des utilités d'une organisation
1h40 avec son sac comme des feuilles
pliées les filatures policières dans
l'opération colisée ont montré nancy
cedeno en train d'échanger des documents
à des trafiquants de drogue
il s'agissait de formulaires pré et en
paix permettant tout mais s'agit de
l'organisation de faire passer de la
drogue sans être fouillés à leur sortie
de l'aéroport
[Musique]
une fois arrêté même si c'est de nous a
tout avoué
mais là on parle de trafic de 3,2 km
tout cela résulte un pays pourtant c'est
le départ comme c'est d'avoir peu seul
au fond un ami jean l'organisation aussi
avait corrompu 12 employés ou ex
employés de l'aéroport
on parle de cette bagagistes et cinq
personnes qui travaillent pour des
compagnies de traiteur qui fournissent
les compagnies aériennes
[Musique]
l'opération colisée a été la plus
importante opération anti-mafia au
canada
[Musique]
grâce aux millions 200 mille
conversation téléphonique que la grc
enregistré des policiers ont constaté
que le clan rizzuto dirigeait une vraie
multinationales du crime qui allait bien
au-delà du trafic de drogue
en fait l'organisation criminelle telle
que l'opération colisée le révéler
fonctionne un peu comme une entreprise
légitime dans le sens où on a au sommet
un espèce de conseil d'administration le
rôle essentiellement c'est de régler des
conflits qui peuvent surgir au sein même
de l'organisation ou avec d'autres
organisations
il ne se salissent jamais les mains
comme très très armes
écoutez un moment donné on parlait de on
parlait que juste vitaux ou vallée à 400
millions ça s'est fait vite et on sait
pas pour le père on ne sait pas pour
paolo renda caussade et cetto à
francesco arcadi tous ces gens adorent
pour blanchir ses millions
l'organisation des régies tôt investi
massivement dans l'économie légale ici
et ailleurs en utilisant des prête-noms
son incursion dans l'industrie de la
construction a été révélée au grand jour
par la police italienne alors que ses
membres ont tenté d'obtenir le contrat
de construction du pont de messine
reliant la sicile au reste de l'italie
un projet de 7 milliards de dollars
l'homme qui les a aidées et d'un autre à
pierre joseph zappia un ingénieur
impliqués dans ce scandale des
dépassements de coûts des jeux
olympiques de montréal en 1976 il est
depuis retourné vivre à rome parce qu on
pourrait vous parler au moment on a
quelques questions vous posez le vieux
joseph zappia qui a aujourd'hui 85 ans a
été condamné au printemps dernier par la
justice italienne à trois ans et demi de
prison avec sursis dans l'histoire du
pont
[Musique]
l' influence du clan rizzuto s'étendait
jusque dans leurs villages d'origine ans
cécile cattolica eraclea où il
contrôlait par l'entremise d'associer
des travaux publics municipaux
la police italienne a effectué l'an
dernier dans ce village une série de
perquisitions et d'arrestations relier
des contrats douteux mais il n'ya pas
que la sicile au québec où si la mafia
était très active dans l'industrie de la
construction comme déclaré à rome le
sergent macdougall le club social était
le quartier général des hauts gradés de
l'organisation rizutto tout le monde
venait s'il avait un message où il
apportait de l'argent pour la famille
plusieurs réunions d'importance s'y
tenait quand il y avait des problèmes
dans la communauté
quand il y avait des problèmes avec
certains contrats possiblement des
contrats en construction il était assez
influent pour donner des contrats à
leurs amis exactement et il prenait un
pourcentage du contrat si je me souviens
bien c'était 5%
c'était la première fois qu'un policier
révélé publiquement l'implication des
principales têtes dirigeantes de la
mafia dans la construction au québec
après la pause le fils de vito rizzuto
le joueur important de la construction
avant qu'il ne soit assassiné
l'icône au resto était quasi
quotidiennement dans les bureaux de
l'entreprise de construction de ton imac
[Musique]
ici au québec on commence à peine à
s'intéresser aux liens entre le monde
interlope et l'industrie de la
construction
or nous avons appris que la police était
réinvesti gay la preuve recueillie dans
le cadre de l'opération colisée à la
recherche de ces liens une piste que
nous avons nous aussi suivi septembre
on inaugure des pavillons de la faculté
de pharmacie de l'université montréal
les pavillons gens et marseille coutume
[Musique]
plusieurs compagnies ont participé à
leur construction parmi celles ci la
compagnie l'indo de québec lors de la
soumission son président avait reçu un
appel mystérieux d'un de ses
compétiteurs dit bon on garde son job
pour moi ça faudrait que tu as c'est un
manteau c'est monique valat vrai nom
jeudi une séance jusqu'à un mois
martin carrier est catégorique
cet appel provient du président de bt
céramique frank bruno un homme qui fait
face actuellement des accusations
criminelles pour avoir produit pour près
de 5 millions de dollars de fausses
factures
frank bruno à qui nous avons parlé au
téléphone nie formellement avoir fait
pression sur monsieur carrier pour qu'il
se retire de l'appel d'offres chose
certaine quelques semaines plus tard
après avoir obtenu le contrat en janvier
du messin que monsieur carrier reçoit un
autre appel cette fois-ci anonyme d'un
individu qui lui fait des menaces
oui oui oui
maeder oui quand même le souhaite je
vais plus effacés je sais pas pourquoi
pas
ok alors mais qu'il s'était aventuré au
pays pour la première fois mais je suis
carrier acceptent de parler publiquement
de cette menace
certains pas le seul à qui c'est arrivé
moi je porte plainte c'est dangereux ces
personnes parlent se passera jamais ring
ça prend quelqu'un qui dénoncent ces
légendes et ça les beatles il se passera
rien sa santé l'homme à l'origine de la
menace contre mu ou carrier et deux
membres influents du clan rizzuto un dur
de dur
francesco del balso il purge
actuellement une peine de 15 ans de
prison pour une série de crimes
notamment trafic de drogue et
gangstérisme
ce dès le berceau se situe juste en deçà
du conseil d'administration de
l'organisation
donc ce n'est pas lui qui prend les
décisions ultime mais il a quand même
voir décerner
très gras radio-canada a retracé un
autre entrepreneur qui dit avoir reçu
des menaces de del balso lors de
l'attribution de contrats dans deux des
trois stations de métro de laval
inauguré en 2007 cet entrepreneur refuse
d'être identifié craignant pour sa
sécurité
d'autres entrepreneurs déclarent avoir
été intimidée par des membres du clan
rizzuto
ces cas de paul sauvé dont les
déclarations ont défrayé la manchette
ces derniers mois concernant les
contrats de réfection de l'hôtel de
ville de montréal et du parlement
d'ottawa
nous on a une déclaration d'un
spécialiste de la grc qui dit que les
rizzuto touchait 5% de gros contrats de
construction oui parce que c'est vrai
tout à fait 5 % ou est lancé de dés des
chefs dans ce temps de rentrer 3 5 vous
est ce que vous vous l'avez vécu chez 5%
on se l'est fait oui on selon on nous a
demandé de payer ces argents la géorgie
le fils le fait le fils de monsieur
restaurant nick rizzuto junior est le
fils de vito rizzuto
selon des sources policières il tentait
de succéder à son père emprisonné aux
états unis avant d'être froidement
abattu en décembre dernier dans le
quartier notre-dame-de-grâce
paul sauvé l'a rencontré à deux reprises
en 2008 et nous dit que il faut payer
il faut payer pour avoir la paix il faut
donner ce fameux 500 mille dollars l'axé
5% que c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
une des deux rencontres avec nick
rizzuto junior a eu lieu au bureau d'un
entrepreneur de l'est de montréal
nous lui avons parlé au téléphone mais
il ne veut pas être nommé
il tentait de convaincre monsieur sauver
de s'entendre avec ses compétiteurs en
présence de régis tôt il voulait tout
avoir
et qu'est-ce que gb comme un conte et tu
parles de gauche est un compétiteur
cet entrepreneur confirme la rencontre
avec nick rizzuto junior mais inique il
était question d'une commission versée
la mafia est ce que c'est vrai que
n'écrit junior a déjà prouvé que s'il
voulait avoir le contrat l'hôtel de
ville
il fallait qu'il lui donne 500 mille
dollars je ne peux pas t'aider
rien de trop parce que prévu que tout
d'abord tourné le dos mais vous n'avez
pas entendu non pas 5 % à la mafia dans
la construction de chemins pentus son
nom est-ce que vous avez pays
non pas du tout d'autres sources nous
ont confirmé l'importance de nick
rizzuto junior d'un secteur de la
construction
avant son assassinat en décembre dernier
nick rizzuto junior était associé dans
divers projets à un des dirigeants de
ftm construction antonio majhi un homme
d'affaires dont le nom apparaît dans
l'épreuve de l'opération colisée les
côtes électronique révèle qu'en 2005
après avoir été victime d'un enlèvement
tout nîmes hadji s'est tourné vers le
clan rizzuto pour retracer ses
kidnappeurs maji a aussi fait la
manchette des faits divers au cours des
dernières années
en 2008 les est sorti miraculeusement
d'une tentative de meurtre
il fait face actuellement à une
accusation de possession d'armes
nicolo rizzuto était quasi
quotidiennement dans les bureaux de
l'entreprise de construction de tony
magi il n'y avait pas que nick rizzuto
junior
une autre figure dirigeants de la mafia
montréalaise pas lourd nda était
propriétaire de la construction celui
qui a été enlevé en mai dernier dans
nord de la ville et qu'on n'a jamais
retrouvé
à luanda entre autres vins du pour deux
millions et demi de dollars des terres
et à hydro québec dont une partie qu'il
avait acquis de ville d'anjou pour une
fraction du prix
quelques années plus tôt plusieurs
autres personnes liées à la mafia rompt
aussi leur entreprise de construction
notamment raynald desjardins proche de
longue date du clan rizzuto qui s'est
recyclé dans la construction après sa
sortie de prison il travaille
actuellement pour le groupe samara qui
fait de la construction résidentielle
je vais de me garder dans le but de
faire que jerry depuis paris mais
raynald desjardins côtoyé au moins une
personne présente dans la preuve colisée
il a travaillé sur un projet de
décontamination de la compagnie
carboneutre dont dominique aux arts
curie le président la preuve recueillis
par les policiers établit clairement que
dominique war curie rencontrait
régulièrement les dirigeants de la mafia
à leur quartier général notamment
françaises coûtent del balso avec qui il
oeuvrait dans secteur immobilier je sais
depuis autrefois directeur général jeff
teague construction dirigée en 2008 la
société de dominique aux arcs uhry il
travaillait conjointement avec son ami
raynald desjardins
andré le monde et notamment à
l'international pour des blâmes
décontamination apports de ce fait avec
lui avec lui avec d'autres avec des
herbes avec l'autre avec d'autres femmes
l'opération colisée visaient
essentiellement les crimes liés au
trafic de drogue ou juge illégaux et à
l'extorsion de fonds or l'émission
enquête à appliquer la police est en
train de réaliser le millions de
conversations enregistrées à la
recherche de liens entre la mafia et
l'industrie de la construction
[Musique]
selon les sources que nous avons
rencontré à montréal et qui a longtemps
frayer avec le clan rizzuto la mafia
touchait beaucoup d'argent
d'entrepreneurs en construction
cette personne qui refuse d'être
identifiée craignant pour sa sécurité
je rendais régulièrement au consenza
cette source confirme le témoignage du
sergent avec google mais en allant
beaucoup plus loin
elle nous a parlé du versement mensuel
de 300 à 500 mille dollars par des
entrepreneurs ou dirigeants du clan
rizzuto pour leur rôle dans
l'organisation de la conclusion du
contrat public à montréal
que c'était les principales têtes
dirigeantes du clan qui avait initié la
mise en place de la collision à montréal
il ya environ dix ans que quatorze
compagnies participait ce qu'on appelait
les abruzzes footing que ces compagnies
se séparait la différence entre le prix
demandé lors des appels d'offres et le
prix fixé par la collusion
le grand patron de l'escouade marteau
confirme l'essentiel de ce témoignage
que le fabulous fourteen existe bel et
bien dans la région de montréal que des
gros joueurs de l'industrie en font
partie que du coach ont payé à la mafia
notre enseignement tend à démontrer
qu'il ya une certaine collusion entre
certaines grandes entreprises de
construction afin de se partager les
contrats on est à établir le phénomène
jusqu'à quelle est l'ampleur du
phénomène au niveau de la mafia on peut
être portant à croire que délié entre
ces entrepreneurs l'eau et la mafia
en fouillant dans les documents de
l'enquète colisée on atteste de l'
échange d'argent entre l'entrepreneur
important de montréal nicolo rizzuto
on raconte qu en 2005 dans une scène
similaire à celle ci à curci au cha cha
qui dirige à tj pavage donne un résultat
de liasses d'argent d'environ un demi
pouce d'épaisseur chacune régit tous
mais une liasse d'argent dans sa
chaussette droite et l'autre dans sa
chaussette gauche rien dans la preuve
colisée n'établit la raison de cet
échange d'argent
l'entrepreneur incursion cha cha a
obtenu pour 22 millions de dollars de
contrats de la ville de montréal au
cours des trois dernières années il a
refusé de répondre à nos questions
un autre ancien dirigeant d'une
compagnie de construction apparaît dans
précisé il s'agit de frank catania dont
l'entreprise qu'il a fondée et l'une des
plus actives dans la région
on a vu frank catania dans des documents
publics qui étaient présents au queen's
a pendant que nicolo rizzuto
mettez de l'argent dans ses chaussettes
l'enquète tunisie nous a appris que les
cinq principaux dirigeants du clan
rizzuto se sont cotisés en 2005 pour
offrir un cadeau à frank catania qui
partait à la retraite monsieur catania
qui nous avons parlé au téléphone
prétend que le cadeau qu'il a reçus
provenaient d'une vingtaine de personnes
et qu'il ignorait s'il s'agissait de
monsieur à partir des rares éléments de
preuve publique de l'enquète colisée
radio-canada autres assis près d'une
vingtaine d'entreprises de construction
qui ont délié avec la mafia des
entrepreneurs qui parfois n'ont pas de
passé criminel mais d'autres impliqués
dans des activités illégales comme le
trafiquant de drogue
nello des réseaux liés à la compagnie
pavages tallarita et qui a obtenu des
millions en contrats municipaux de fer
dans la région de montréal
s'agit-il de la pointe de l'iceberg
la police enquête mais l'épreuve reste
très difficile à faire
habituellement ces entrepreneurs le les
entrepreneurs qui sont problématiques
ont tendance à vouloir noyer le poisson
avec une multitude de compagnies donc
c'est la façon de d'éviter qu'on est
curieux sont capables de remonter
jusqu'à aux têtes dirigeantes et de bien
cibler l'horreur les joies les plus
importants
[Musique]
en attendant l'aboutissement des
enquêtes de marteau il est clair que le
clan rizzuto a été affaiblie dans ces
opérations légale illégale par
l'opération colisée
déjà il ya cinq ans les déclarations de
nicolas varacalli montré de premiers
signes de vulnérabilité du clan ben ali
[Musique]
depuis cet avertissement plusieurs
membres du clan ont été assassinés des
cafés italiens sont régulièrement la
cible n'est pas tellement le top
dans la construction le système mafieux
de collusion 100 boutiques complètement
déstabilisé on constate en effet que les
prix des grands travaux publics depuis
les premiers scandales ont diminué de
façon marquée entre autre à montréal de
plus de 30%
ça fait donc beaucoup moins d'argent
distribuées et à dissimuler dans des
chaussettes
[Musique]